hello everyone welcome back to the
channel for an interview you could
already tell i'm very excited about not
only do i get to talk stranger things
four but i get to talk about one of my
favorite shows out there with robert
england of all people when you popped up
in stranger things four if only you were
able to see the utter delight on my face
congratulations i'm so happy you're in
the show
well thank you and you know i'm a fanboy
myself and i'm i'm really honored to be
on the show
it's it's such a terrific mixture of uh
80s nostalgia and horror and science
fiction and and i'm a big fan of of so
many of the kids and and david harbour
and
i have a crush on winona ryder and i
love millie bobby brown and i was really
excited to get to work with uh with
natalie and with maya too oh i can't
wait to get into your collaboration with
them but i wanted to start back at the
very very beginning because i was
reading that the duffers were surprised
to see your audition tape pop up when
they were going through them so many
questions about that i guess how did you
hear about the new season's nightmare on
elm street spin and did you decide on
your own to submit that tape or was that
something that carmen cuba encouraged
you to do
well you know i'm not sure i know all of
the details i had
uh i i misfired on an audition for
season three
uh and uh i probably went the wrong way
with the character or something and i
really wanted to be on the show i was
disappointed and uh i
got the call
or the submission for um
season four uh it just came through my
agent i i i guess it can it may have
my agent might have submitted me or
carmen might have contacted her i'm not
sure which uh and i you know crawled
into my bathtub with an old bathrobe on
and my wife sat on the toilet seat and
filmed me with her smartphone
and i sent it in and i got a pretty
quick response
so uh
i think it's because i realized that i
would be narrating a lot of flashback
as well as um being on camera as victor
creel and i wanted to kind of link it
emotionally
and i've i've played a lot of roles
recently
last five five to eight years where i'm
the you know i'm the old priest
uh i'm the old scientist
i'm the old poacher i i tell the back
story you know the old the old doctor
who tells the back story the exposition
uh
in a movie and i had and i've done that
a lot so i kind of saw that
victor it was also bored that resp you
know carried that responsibility and
that may be what won me the role i have
so many follow-ups first you mind me
asking which audition you misfired for
in season three and what it was about
reading victor's monologue that really
clicked and felt right to you
well i as i said let me answer the
second part of that question first i i'd
play a lot of parts recently it's a sort
of natural progression
because i've been loyal to the horror
genre and science fiction and fantasy uh
that i have matured into
these roles there's always seems to be
somebody that needs to tell the
backstory the exposition
and he might be the guy at the fishing
store where the kids all go into the
woods you know it might be the old
priest that knows the story of evil in
the town it might be the scientist that
knows about the experiments that went on
and you know in the hospital back in the
1940s but i've been playing
a lot of those roles
and so so
that's the answer to the first the
second part of your question the first
part
um i i think they
they read me for the mayor
and uh i don't know if i was supposed to
read or just meet with somebody and i
drove up to hollywood and uh i
i didn't get to meet with anybody so i
read for
uh somebody on carmen's staff
and i i don't know whether they changed
the concept for the role or whether i i
did a sucky audition i know that they
said to me uh read it like the mayor in
from jaws
and now that's one of my favorite
character actors murray hamilton who
played that role in joshua so i
immediately thought of the plaid jacket
you know
and sunglasses and kind of like a
corrupt you know kind of southern
you know thing and that's and that's
probably not what they wanted at all but
when they said the mayor and jaws to me
that's what i saw in my mind's eye so i
probably canceled myself out without
audition but i was really grateful
uh
when they contacted me again for season
four and that's a much better fit victor
creel i imagine that was disappointing
at the time but it does feel like it was
very much meant to be i mean the the
nightmare on elm street echoes this
season are really something special and
one thing i wanted to ask you because
like i do tend to hear a lot about
artists out there trying to distance
themselves from the iconic roles that
they're so well known for but you've
already said you really embraced the
horror community but now on top of that
you're jumping into a project that has
so many layers that feel similar to
nightmare on elm street so what is it
about nightmare on elm street and that
kind of scenario that makes you feel
creatively fulfilled digging back into
the idea
well you know i have such a strange
career i began
i played
best friends and sidekicks
for 10 years in the 70s jan michael
vincent henry fonda
peter strauss
dennis christopher jeff bridges arnold
schwarzenegger i was always the buddy
the pal the sidekick
but
in contemporary terms those don't age as
well they used to back in the 30s 40s
and 50s but not any longer they don't
want
old men to have old buddies that's not
grumpy old men that's sort of a one-off
um
so i i i realized at the end of the 70s
i was changing myself and i started
playing bad guys
and then i did of all things this nerdy
sci-fi uh character on tv and it was the
number one miniseries and it was an
international hit and i i was submitted
for an emmy and and i thought you know
i'm going to be typed as this sort of
nerdy doctor spock
good alien on this miniseries i need to
do something else and in my hiatus
i did nightmare in elm street and that
simultaneously also became an
international hit
and
people finally learned my name
they put the name to my face
and you you can't predict her career and
i was so embraced
by the fanboys and the fan girls in the
horror
science fiction community and it opened
so many doors for me internationally
that i sort of was very low i just
became very loyal to that uh over the
years now i've done
in the interim i've done disney movies
and lots of other things
and lots of voice work and comedies
sitcoms and guest stars but you know i
am
i get respect within the genre uh and i
get a better payday i'll be honest you
know uh if you see me
on criminal minds or on hawaii 5-0 or
something like that
that's
or bones shows like that that's just
robert england the you know veteran
actor just a utility actor but when you
see me in in one of my little horror
movies in europe or or or in in america
or in canada i'm
i don't want to say a star salary but
i'm i'm handsomely paid for those so i
try to and i have the a fan base for
those and i like to do them for the fans
and for my pocketbook
as someone who has been part of the
nightmare on elm street fandom since i
guess as
as old as i had to be to actually watch
the movies which is probably way too
young for most i very much appreciate
all the time you put into that community
because it's a very special one is that
a scream mask over your shoulder
so this is the scream poster but i opted
for the nightmare on elm street pocket
tea today all right i love the part
there's many many many more where this
came from so
even with all of your experience on tons
of sets over the years what would you
say surprised you the most about the
reality of working on an episode of one
of the biggest netflix series ever made
well you know we were at the end of
covid protocols
and uh i had
seen my makeup on me in london in a
bathroom
uh the great barry gower and duncan
jarmon who did game of thrones
they you know invented the night king
amongst other great uh special effects
makeups i knew they had my back and i
knew what i looked like so
i was not anxious about the makeup
and i knew the makeup
i was essentially blind in the makeup i
had a pinhole that worked in one eye but
i you know no peripheral vision
and it was very very dark and if i moved
at all it sometimes the makeup adjusted
and i couldn't see it all so i did not
have to act blind
and then the other happy accident of the
nature of that scene is
that i'm i'm in a cell i've been in for
20 years well a blind person would know
every square inch of it they would make
themselves familiar with it i wouldn't
have to walk around with my hands
extended or tap a cane or any of those
cliches i didn't have to devote any
energy to that
because
victor would know his space he would
know where his bed and his chair and his
desk and where the bars were he would
have had counted those paces off so many
times that that would be instinctual to
him so i was freed of all of that
performance energy and i could just
concentrate on the story and the
emotional truth
uh and my only concern was linking
the emotional
reality of the scene that i had with
robin and nancy to
carry it over into the voice over
narration and and we were able to do
that sean
recorded some of that double uh but he
recorded it in the cell immediately
after i did the scene so that i was
still in character which was a very
smart thing for him to do i thought so
you already mentioned that you have a
lot of experience doing voice over
backstory in shows and movies so for
anyone out there who's maybe going to
tackle that kind of performance for the
very first time what's like one key
piece of advice that you would give them
in order to make sure that they're not
just conveying the information but
they're conveying it in a dynamic and
engaging way which you very much do here
i think the trick is
respect the writer respect the writer
respect the writing
and trust the rhythms but also
if there's a place where you can
uh inflict a little personality
i think it's all right
i think it's all right to be a little
judgmental sometimes because otherwise
it's real easy to fall into that
academic
disk jockey sound and you you want to
avoid that i mean the the real
breakthrough i found for most voice over
narration work
especially in documentaries was ken
burns original civil civil war
and that really it was like that's what
i've always had always wanted to do
i'm i'm
i would love to be invited to work for
ken burns at some point but i when i
heard civil war the first time that was
what i'd always wanted to do when i had
done voiceover work before and the one
place i was able to do it was a a 70s
feature film by the great john millius
called big wednesday his sort of owed
to to to surfing of of his youth surfing
in the in the late 50s and early 60s and
of course john wrote
the the the classic scene in jaws
about the sharks attacking the sailors
and everything so you really trust
john's writing and his rhythms but i was
also able i pinched my nose a little bit
and got that kind of nasal quality
of of a young surfer a surfer in his 30s
maybe her 40s looking back under the
wonderful years of of late adolescence
or early 20s that they all had you know
when everything was free and easy and
wonderful and sunny and endless summer
i feel like you should do some audiobook
narration i i listen to audiobooks
non-stop and i would totally be down to
have you read me a book
uh well my wife's listening to ulysses
right now
uh and i think it's like an 80s
recording from the irish
the dublin players or the irish
repertory theater she said it's great
that's so cool there's so much variety
like that out there i love it i did want
to bring back working with natalya and
maya here because a big part of that
scene is that you know they need to
convince victor to share his story with
them so was there anything about their
performance in that respect and what
they gave to you as scene partners that
maybe pulled something out of victor
that you wouldn't have been able to
access otherwise
well i i didn't see how they were
dressed
and they're dressed rather humorously
because they're pretending to be
academics
what they think academics look like
so i just heard the voices and just
listened to them
and you know you you wait for things to
key on and and early on natalya has a
line
that really gets to me you know that
that it could be happening again it
could be and this may be
not certain yet but this may be
one of the denials that victor is in he
may have suspected
that there was something wrong with
henry
his wife certainly did that that's
revealed in later episodes
uh in the season so there was that but i
also knew how wonderful they are um
and you know i had watched season three
uh several times in my preparation
and
one of the scenes that stuck with me in
season three
really
charmed me
and and and and kind of blew my mind a
little there's a scene
in the bathroom the ugly soiled
fluorescent lighting
urinal of a bathroom at the mall
at the end of all the chaos in the mall
and it's maya hawk
and it's joe keely
coming down
off of russian psychedelics that's that
have been given to them and they've
escaped
and they're exhausted and they're
sitting on the floor of of a public
bathroom
in the destroyed mall
and
there's been seasons of flirting at
chips ahoy
uh with maya and and and with joe and
and it's unrequited and joe
is beginning to
kind of
become smitten
with robin
uh steven's becoming a little smitten
with her and they're exhausted and he
pulls himself
the bottom of the of the stalls in the
public bathroom into the stall she's in
and they're both there leaning against
the sides and
and and and she gently comes out to him
and it's just a remarkable remarkable
scene and because i watched season three
several times
i became a little obsessed with how
great the acting was in that scene and i
didn't get to meet joe to tell him how
great it was but it actually reminded me
in some strange weird way of james dean
and julie harris at the top of the
ferris wheel in east of eden just this
great wonderful scene and i
i you know i i just wanted maya to know
that but i was so impressed with it that
i you know she could have improvised
with me she could have done anything she
wanted because i knew i saw in that
scene with joe i saw how wonderful she
was and i've subsequently seen her work
with her father and in other films and i
know how terrific she is and you know
and she's responsible for x amount of
the comedy relief you know just like
like some of the other kids are and the
new actor on the show um joseph quinn
who plays eddie munson and and he's
batting a thousand for me he's just you
know he's getting all it he's landing on
all his jokes just right but i mean it
really extraordinarily talented kids you
know without a doubt exceptional
ensemble here i'll end with this last
one for you it's kind of more theorizing
but
i guess do you think that there's any
hope for victor at this point if you
know he eventually comes to learn the
truth of what happens to his son and
what's really going on in this situation
is there anything at all that'll kind of
set him free
well victor's guilt is certainly about
the fact that he wasn't able to save his
family
could be that he was in denial about
henry it could be
that he
was and this is the metaphor that is
blind
to what was going on and that's why he
blinded himself
oedipus
slept with his mother and blinded
himself victor
didn't see the evil in his son and it
cost him his family and he blinded
himself i mean that's an academic
essay that you could turn in in film
school about stranger things than victor
creel but and you know and i use a
little bit of that like i use a little
bit
of ben gunn for some reason came into my
head from treasure island uh the the the
old blind man that tells jim hawkins the
boy
backstory on john silver
long john silver but but i
i don't know whether it's
appropriate for victor to be redeemed he
made the terrible mistake in world war
ii
the baby died a family died
he called in a shelling of an innocent
farmhouse
and if whether or not he sensed anything
wrong
with his son that he could have acted
upon as a strong father and stopped and
prevented you know with with the dead
animals with the dead animals or
anything else so it could have been some
of that
but the other thing
is that i believe
vecna has a line and it may be when i
don't know whether it's sam or nancy's
walking in the sort of salvador dali uh
uh uh
underworld uh uh upside down and
you hear vecna talking i think it's to
nancy
and he talks about me he says you know
oh victor old billy old grumpy victor
you know
never got back to him maybe i should
i've been so so busy so i don't know
what that means does he going to kill me
you know does he want to punish me
more than i've already been punished i
don't understand what that meant or if
they feel they need to pay that off
there's so many loose ends that have to
be resolved in season five you know
we've got to get winona and david
out of russia oh my god uh so we'll have
to see but uh i'm just so honored and
happy to be part of this
kind of miraculous franchise that is uh
you know stranger things you should be
very proud i love the season thus far
but in particular episode four is above
and beyond my favorite so huge huge huge
congratulations and i can't wait to talk
to you again for another project you're
always such a delight and tree to talk
to
all right thank you
you